here with reaction Texas Senator Ted
Cruz Senator um I saw your comments
about Mitch mcconell rightly I think
you're very angry with him um ran Paul
did you hear the same thing he heard
that he didn't want people like me
getting the information about the bill
did you hear that I I did and this whole
thing has been a disaster from the very
beginning it's been a disaster on policy
and it's been a disaster on Politics on
policy this bill is terrible it is an
absolute it is a bill that Chuck Schumer
wanted that is designed not to secure
the Border not just not to secure the
Border it's designed to make it worse so
this bill as you noted it codifies Joe
Biden's open borders Catch and Release
the cause of this crisis it codifies
catch and release it puts it into the
law not only that it
normalizes 5,000 illegal immigrants a
day that works out to 1.8 million a year
that works out to about 6 million
illegal immigrants over the three years
of Biden we have in fact seen 9.6
million illegal immigrants so so the
idiotic Republican proposal was let's be
for 2third of the Border Invasion that
Biden has allowed that made no sense not
only did it put it into law 1.8 million
every year in perpetuity but it also put
into law giving those illegal immigrants
work permits giving them lawyers paid
for by the taxpayers it gave billions of
dollars to Sanctuary cities to keep
their policies going and it gave
billions of dollars to left-wing
nonprofit organizations that are
bringing the illegal immigrants in so it
funds the process and I'll tell you the
provision that just is a Texan that
pissed me off the most it it went
directly after the state of Texas and it
said any litigation filed challenging
this law has to be filed in Washington
DC and federal district court so Texas
can't sue in the federal courts in Texas
where Texas has been winning instead
that got to go to Washington with the
very liberal judges this was a disaster
on policy grounds because it did not
solve the problem but politically it was
even worse who won in this battle and
and his name is Charles Schumer Chuck
Schumer did this he knew it would fail
he wanted it to fail but the purpose of
this bill was to let every Democrat
running for the Senate and running for
the house to stand up and say
self-righteously I I wanted to secure
the Border I really wanted to but those
mean Republicans wouldn't let me and I
got to say Senate Republican leadership
I told them this months ago other
conservatives told them this months ago
and they proceeded down this this path
that ended up it was a box canyon with a
kamakazi pilot crashing into a wall it
was a disaster and it was entirely
avoidable because what happened his
Republican leadership ended up
benefiting Chuck Schumer and the
Democrats and doing nothing thing to
secure the border the amazing part about
all of this Senator is there is no need
for Biden to get legislation from
anybody he through the just the stroke
of the pen as I've been pointing out put
back in place the policies that were
successful here's one interesting thing
I noted in your home state of Texas
99.99% of illegal immigration and Eagle
Pass where you put up the razor wire it
is ended it shows the barriers work and
now they move to California and Arizona
uh and if Texas can build out more razor
wire I say they should continue doing
what they're doing cuz it
worked Texas is going to continue
leading the fight and and we've got to
this crisis it is massive it it is
devastating and we've got to lead the
fight and you know what Joe Biden is
doing Joe Biden is siding with the
Mexican drug cartels against the
American people I got to say the image
of just a few days ago of those six
illegal aliens who beat up two New York
police officers it was disgusting and
they got arrested and of course what
happens they get released from jail with
no bail and what do they do walking out
they flip the bird on both hands walking
out that image Sean is the image of of
this campaign in 2024 that image
flipping the bird is what Joe Biden and
the Democrats in the Senate are saying
to every American they stand with the
drug cartels the human traffickers the
illegal immigrants the criminals and
they stand against law enforcement and
they stand against American families
that's the message of this radical
policy and we got to stand up and fight
against it 272 days there an election
Senator your election is important too
uh and I know you're being targeted but
uh you were the first person I called
when the bill came out I said Senator am
I reading this correctly and you said
yes you're reading it correctly um but
it's sad
um the fact that they didn't want the
people to be know the details that
speaks volumes about the current
leadership good for people like you and
the Senate that hold them accountable
Ted Cruz thank you sir Sean Republican
leadership wanted to hide it from you
and from the American people and I
appreciate your pointing out Chuck
Schumer and George Soros are coming
after me hard so I want to encourage
folks go to tedcruz.org I need your help
we're going to fight to defend Texas and
defend this country we're going to be
down in Texas and hopefully we'll see
you and we'll go tore the Border
together that Joe Biden has left wide
open hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else